et
on fasse maintenant un autre terrain du
samedi soir
[Musique]
sebastian marocaine bonsoir
bonsoir
vous êtes né le 24 février
1977 à medellin de l'union entre maria
victoria et now est incertain pablo
escobar votre vrai nom est donc juan
pablo escobar et now vous êtes le fils
de pablo escobar alors la vraie histoire
de pablo escobar plus que dans la série
narcose dont vous avez révélé les
incohérences elle est dans le livre
publié chez hugo doc qui s'appelle pablo
escobar mon père
quand vous naissez votre mère à 15 ans
et votre père 27 il est en prison ça
veut dire que quand votre mère était
enceinte de vous l aller voir votre père
en prison
on peut dire que j'ai rendu visite à mon
père en prison dès le ventre de ma mère
alors dès votre plus jeune âge ou
partager votre quotidien avec les plus
grands criminels de colombie herpès les
cas l'on se trouve
dick lourd c'était qui
s'était un peu mais baby sitter en fait
c'est avec eux que j'ai grandi savais
que j'étais lever beaucoup de parents à
l'époque interdisent à leurs enfants de
jouer avec vous vous avez souffert de ça
quand vous étiez petit
en fait j'ai pas vraiment eu le choix de
ce que j'allais faire demain vie parce
que j'avais simplement à m'adapter à ma
réalité et au collège à l'école je
voyais que les enfants s'éloigner de moi
même si on avait
peut-être la possibilité d'être amis
mais c'était pas possible
l'après midi après je voyais les parents
de ces enfants qui travaillent avec le
bien ouais il veut dire que vous êtes un
écolier particulier qui dès la
maternelle circulent rhône cruiser
blindé avec un garde du corps ainsi s si
c'est vrai c'est cette partie de la
sécurité que nous proposer mon père
parce qu'il avait peur qu'on soit enlevé
par la guérilla de l'époque
fait j'avais quelqu'un toujours avec moi
que je sois à l'intérieur de la classe
ou en dehors la personne était toujours
à l'extérieur et surveiller la porte si
je sortais à la récréation il était à
mes côtés tout le temps c'était facile
de savoir étiez parmi les milliers
d'enfants où j'étais parce qu'il y avait
toujours le garde du corps à mon côté
alors vous grandissez dans l'hacienda de
napo laisse alors c'était énorme c'est
la sienne date pablo escobar il y avait
une station d'essence une carrosserie 27
lac cent mille arbres fruitiers un
jurassic park et des vrais dinosaures
grandeur nature
bien avant le film de spielberg deux
héliports une piste d'atterrissage
1700 employés un jo et 10 résidences
alors un jour et vous raconter ça dans
votre livre c'est incroyable vous allez
dans la chambre de votre père et là vous
découvrez une cache d'armes
c'était assez courant dans la vie de mon
père de découvrir des caches est en
permanence de fait tout récemment on a
encore découvert que certaines cachait
dans ses anciennes propriétés alors
c'était quelqu'un de très discret qui
remet et caché beaucoup de choses alors
à l'époque tout va pour le mieux pour
pablo escobar et sa famille mais votre
père a un problème il ne veut pas rester
un vulgaire trafiquant de drogue au delà
du pouvoir économique
il veut le pouvoir politique sait ce
qu'il a perdu en fait
sofres au port ça a été sa pire erreur
oui de vouloir rentrer dans l'une des
plus grandes mafias qui existe ouais
plus dangereuse que l'autre
je pense que oui parce que décide
finalement ce qui se passe dans le monde
alors vient non pas bleu escobar arrive
à se faire élire suppléant la chambre
des congrès et à partir de là évidemment
il jouit de l'immunité parlementaire ce
qui était un petit peu le but recherché
et il veut faire annuler l'extradition
systématique des états unis série
comprend pas pourquoi la colombie livre
ces trafiquants aux états unis alors
qu'ils pourraient du géant colombie et
il a lutté longtemps pour obtenir sa
facture mais effectivement ce fut l'un
de ceux qui a dit qu'il préférait une
tombe en colombie qu'une prison aux
états unis ouais et la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça a changé les
narcotrafiquants on préfère aujourd'hui
négocier rapidement réglée états unis
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils en sortent
très vite de la prison alors votre père
continue malgré le fait qu'ils soient au
congrès le commerce de la drogue
c'est là que le ministre de la justice
lara lui déclare la guerre votre père va
aussi le faire assassiner donc là ça
commence à être très très très violent
ça devient une lutte personnelle en sort
de la politique et mon père essaie de
convaincre le ministre avec de l'argent
avec des menaces et le ministre bien
entendu quelqu'un d'honnête il ne veut
pas céder et finalement sur les coûts de
la vie
mr un jour des sites d'assassiner le
ministre c'est ce jour là qui se retire
aussi de la politique alors vous partez
avec votre mère qui est enceinte de huit
mois vous cacher au panama à ce moment
là et là changement complet de style de
vie vous vivez dans un appartement
minable vous mangez au kfc vous prenez
des douches avec des sandales pour
éviter la crasse
après le général noriega nous a prêté
une résidence très jolie où nous avons
pu vivre après
durées longues dans ces six jeunes les
choses ne durent pas trop cette vie oui
parce que les négociations entre votre
père et le gouvernement colombien sont
divulguées par le journal el tiempo et
là vous devez fuir à nouveau vous aller
au nicaragua
v 7 ans à l'époque c'est une vie quand
même très compliqué quand on est un
enfant
depuis l'âge de 7 ans je fuis et je me
cache comme si moi j'avais d'ordonner
les assassinats de tout le monde a
poursuivi est aussi
que pour les autorités c'est difficile
de faire la différence entre fils et
perrin alors ensuite c'est le retour en
colombie
pablo escobar obtient enfin
l'abolition de l'extradition sans
procédure et ce répit vous permet de
vous installer dans un luxueux duplex de
l'immeuble monaco à medellin comme un
duplex qui faisait 15 cents mètres
carrés quand même et vous aviez de la
place j'ai beaucoup d'argent
c'était pas facile à nettoyer par contre
et là votre mère qui était assez marrant
quand vous avez fait votre première
communion elle a envoyé en jet privé le
cuisinier de la famille en suisse pour
choisir les chocolats ensuite à paris
pour choisir du petrus 71 alors il y
avait vingt bouteilles de pétrus 71 vous
en avez bien la poubelle m'adresse voir
pourquoi
parce qu'un ignorant a dit qu'elle était
trop vieille
mais un jour une voiture piégée est
lancé contre l'immeuble monaco la dalle
de béton du toit s'effondre sur vous
c'est votre mère encore une fois qu'ils
ont un effort surhumain arrive à vous
sortir de là des débris de l'immeuble
c'est un miracle comme ayant survécu
douze personnes deux hommes ont essayé
le lendemain de soulever le toit que ma
mère a soulevés tout seul pour me sauver
pour que tu te fasses une idée de
l'ampleur de l'explosion dans un
kilomètre à la ronde les vitres la ville
ont complètement explosé dans diarios
annoncé le lendemain les journaux
annoncé que medenine s'était réveillée
comme beyrouth
en fait c'est pas du tout la police qui
a fait remonter ça c'est le cartel de
quel parce que désormais votre père
pablo escobar a deux ennemis le
gouvernement colombien et le cartel de
cali le chanteur
après la police nous a mis aussi des
bombes quand votre père finit par
libérer ces derniers otages
le gouvernement propose qu'il soit
enfermé dans une prison construite par
lui même qui s'appelait la cathédrale
cinq ans connaissance de l'histoire qui
a financé et construit sa propre prison
qui a ordonné au gouvernement quelles
lois il fallait qu'il prenne pour qu'ils
puissent
en profite et lorsqu'ils se rendent et
volontairement entre guillemets le fait
est que mon père a soumis le
gouvernement à sa volonté à travers le
terrorisme c'est un enlèvement l'un
votre père va bleus escobar mène une vie
assez confortable dans cette prison il
réorganise son cartel sous le nez du
gouvernement en fait il gérait ses
affaires tout à fait normalement
au début il laisser entrer la presse
lorsqu'il avait rien et puis dès que la
presse est parti c'est les jacuzzis les
téléviseurs qui sont qui sont rentrés
tout ce qui avait de bons quoi alors
jusqu'au jour où les autorités
colombiennes veulent transférer dans une
autre prison et là votre père réussit à
s'échapper de la cathédrale en fait
quand il avait fait construire la prison
il avait prévu un mur très facile à
écroulé et il s'échappe
effectivement oui c'était l'une des
choses qui nous faisait penser que notre
père avait toujours un coup d'avancé par
rapport aux autres c'est lui qui a
dessiné sa prison et donc il a dessiné
son plan d'évasion avant même la prison
et l'armée colombienne a mis 12 heures à
comprendre comment savait plus passer
alors pablo escobar battle est à nouveau
en fuite l'escaladé de la violence
continue il a fait quand même explosé
pas moins de douze voitures piégées à
medellin à votre père quand même
je crois que c'est un peu le début de la
fin père d'avoir choisi de chapet de
cette prison c'est sans aucun doute ce
qui a marqué sa fin beaucoup de ses
anciens amis se sont rassemblés contre
lui et ils ont décidé de l'éliminer vous
même été arrêté à l'âge de 15 ans et
vous dites aux policiers qui nous arrête
mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai rien
fait bah non ils disent nous on veut
juste s'amuser un petit peu avec le fils
de pablo escobar voilà
arrêtée à sept ans et mercer avec
quelques mois lorsqu'elle a été
emprisonnée aux mains de la police
colombienne
ce type d'agissement de la police l'a
finalement ça faisait que donner des
excuses à mon père pour de la violence
contre eux
on perd 10 et que la seule différence
entre la police et lui et ses hommes
s'étaient l'uniforme à partir de là
votre père à de nouveaux ennemis un
groupe de justiciers affirmant avoir été
persécuté par escobar qui s'appelle los
peces
effectivement qui rassemble l ensemble
des cartels de la drogue en colombie
plus les autorités et non seulement
nationale mais également cia et europe
et ils voulaient tous l'éliminer alors
il dynamique la maison de votre grand
mère
heureusement la vieille dame était
absente là vous projetez de fuir un
miami mais la brigade anti-terroriste
vous retardés à l'aéroport en
multipliant les contrôles enfants vous
hanche et pour tout dire et là vous êtes
très malin vous arrivez à soudoyer un
mec et ont quitté l'aéroport ont tous
les cas en hélicoptère et votre père
vous félicite pour ça
s'en est tiré par miracle parce que les
autorités de l'époque ont également
permis que 25 terroristes rentrer en
plein jour dans l'aéroport pour nous
tuer ou nous enlever malheureusement les
usa annuler votre visa ce qui va vous
obliger à changer très très fréquemment
de cachettes enfin une vie rd-congolais
sq jusqu'au jour où votre père pablo
escobar est abattu par les pps mais en
fait ça a été revendiqué par la police
colombienne on est d'accord
en réalité mon père ma place mais il
s'est suicidé il a décidé de se laisser
trouver le 2 décembre 1993 et la police
elle même aujourd'hui se contredit il ya
un colonel qui jure qu'il l'a tué et un
général qui dit au colonel qui l'a pas
tué donc même entre eux ils se mettent
pas d'accord
ça et je sais que c'était mon père parce
qu'il ya plein de preures j'ai parlé
avec les légistes jeanne le travail de
trajet de la balle aussi dans sa tête
toujours expliquer comment il allait se
suicider il m'avait appris à
me suicider correctement pour être moins
sur le coup et le tir est arrivé
exactement là où lui m'avait dit qu'il
le mettrait est pour nous la mort ce
n'est pas un tabou ou la possibilité du
suicide s'était pas un tabou face à des
ennemis qui cite attrapant vie à les
torturer et jusqu'à ta sa cité quand
votre père s'est suicidé vous venez de
lui parler au téléphone en fait
je parlais avec lui et finalement une
journaliste dix minutes après m'informe
que mon père était mort alors au début
j'ai eu du mal à croire parce que bien
sûr laps de temps si court entre l'appel
téléphonique et la nouvelle que que j'y
crois pas donc j'ai commis l'erreur de
menacer le pays de réagir à chaud et de
dire des démos très courts à 1 5 seconde
mais qui aujourd'hui demeure et je vis
toujours en exil là vous aviez deux
possibilités effectivement la première
s'est vengé votre père et c'est ce que
vous avez déclaré
sur le moment mais ça se comprend bon
mais en fait l'autre solution qui était
de s'occuper de votre famille c'est
celle que vous avez choisi est ce que
vous faites c'est ce que j'aimais bien
longtemps c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
que des menaces dans la bouche du fils
de pablo escobar ses clients sérieux et
moi je n'étais pas conscient de ça là
vous êtes dépossédés de tous les biens
de votre père évidemment en colombie ou
changer de nom vous devenez donc
sebastian marocaine et vous vous
installer à buenos aires s ouvent vous
obtenez un diplôme d'architecturé donc
vous rentrer vraiment dans une vie je
dirais normal vous marier avec la
bénédiction de l'archevêque de buenos
aires est ce qui n'est autre que le
patron soit
effectivement il faut la personne vise à
autoriser
mon mariage
église parce que l'église exigé que ça
ait lieu dans un environnement
religieuse des relances unique liste les
pornos pour des raisons de sécurité on
pouvait pas exploser la famille donc
lui très facilement compris cette
réalité et il a accepté il a autorisé
que l'on se marie à l'extérieur de
l'église vous allez rencontrer le patron
soit
je vais revoir colombie prochainement
alors il ya une question qui me taraude
l'esprit comment expliquez-vous que
votre père qui était quand même un
trafiquant de drogue séminal comment
expliquez vous qu'il ait une bonne image
que les gens ne l'aiment bien c'est dû à
quoi
bon je crois que
pas se tromper pablo escobar connu
aujourd'hui grâce aux séries de
télévision où l'on glorifie sur
l'activité criminelle beaucoup pensent
que c'est un héros
je n'oserais jamais glorifier les crimes
de mon père ni son comportement mais
c'est vrai aussi qu'il a été beaucoup de
jambes de pauvres gens et la donne et
des logements des milliers de logements
aux pauvres des centres de santé des
centres
paradoxalement pour qu'il ne consomme
pas de drogues financés par l'argent de
la vie de mon père est rempli de
contradictions c'est quelqu'un qui
avait des idées de gauche
qui a fondé des groupes paramilitaires
de droite d'ultra-droite sa vie était
très fluctuant oui il a aidé les pauvres
parce qu'il pensait que c'était son
devoir et c'est comme ça qu'elle a
acheté l'amour et la protection des
pauvres que pensez vous de la série
marcos qui a tellement de succès
un article que l'on appelle l'art co2 et
les 24 8 mensonges parce que je pensais
qu'il était important de montrer à la
jeunesse que l'histoire quand d'ailleurs
comme le raconte dès qu'on leur vend
comme la véritable histoire de pablo
escobar n'a rien à voir avec la réalité
je ne peux pas être d'accord avec des
produits qui incite à ce que cette ville
mon père soit réitérée j'aime mon père
mais je ne répèterai pas son histoire
merci de votre série c'est encore la
voix voulez vous nous révéler ce que
vous cacher sous votre bureau
oh [ __ ]
merci thierry
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu